Talking about three or four years old,
I drove Walgett time,
do all the time.
Every second.
I worked at my,
when I worked at my father's flowers to
it,
he was at from the old country and he
was a Greek immigrant law with my
mother.
But when I worked at,
I worked at a store.
I just had a good week.
A shot always did.
I drew all the time.
And when I was in the store and I wasn't
actually working,
I was drawing,
drawing,
drawing.
Yeah.
It was at a high school music and art.
I call it the greatest school of
learning since Alexander sat at the feet
of aristotle.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I took design courses,
you a long history of art courses along
with academic courses.
And I had a flat for whatever that
means,
but that the,
at the very beginning of the design
courses,
they were,
uh,
basically,
you know,
kind of a retro,
uh,
you know,
condensed means and Herbert and Herbert
matters and the poor clays.
And we did design with circles and then
we did a design with circles and
triangles and circles,
triangles,
squares,
etc.
Time.
And I'm aT the end of my very first term
after doing that for a term,
I go along with all my other courses.
Uh,
he,
uh,
mr pAtterson gave us an eight to a
beautiful 18 by 24 sheet of strathmore
expensive sheets must have cost at least
accordIng to those days,
which was big bucks.
And uh,
he said,
uh,
what we're going to do it in the next
hour and a half will be a one half year
mark for the term,
you know,
we had done dozens and dozens of them
and he said,
um,
and the subject,
this time is rectangles,
period.
And everybody started to.
And I just sat there for an hour and a
half and I didn't move,
just kind of looked around the room and
he was furious,
you know,
you could see walking around with it.
Everybody visited help cutting out
squares and you know,
and to a shape.
He had dual doing mala bitches,
you know,
malibu red shaped for blue chip.
And I didn't move and a lady said time's
up and he started to pick up english,
but she was turning red and he came up
to me to me any,
any went that grabbed my 18 by 24 sheet
and I said,
hold that,
met it Mr.
Patterson.
And I go by my name,
my signature in the corner,
and I handed him a 18 by 24 rectangle
and he still didn't get it.
He was furious and tornado.
And I said,
oh my god,
he didn't get it.
I,
oh boy.
and I came into the next morning and
there were two or three teachers in the
hallway who stopped me and they said,
george,
what you get for mr patterson's class
was brilliant.
So he obviously had gone into the locker
room,
was somethIng you and as they will leave
in school.
And he said that george lois,
he said,
terrific student athletes.
He to an 18 by 20.
Yeah.
He really did nothing.
He just had to be an 18 by 24 rectangle.
Anyway,
that was kind of a.
I've always said that was my epiphany
myself and induced an epiphany when I,
when I realized that,
uh,
and,
and I made the public who relate to high
school of music and art that any,
that,
any problem,
any design problem and a communications
problem,
that there's a chance to do something
unusual,
exciting,
dramatic,
unique,
um,
and um,
and I,
and my whole career is based on the fact
that everything I work on,
what I have to create,
whether it's a advertisement or,
you know,
a,
a music video,
a magazine cover,
promotion piece,
uh,
that the,
that the got to be totally surprising
and unique and almost and thrilling.
I'm a social somehow in that first year
at,
at high school in Michigan on,
I knew I was going to be some kind of a.
I'm a commUnicator,
a designer,
and,
and also,
uh,
I wish really inspired me greatly by,
the work of paul rand who at that tiMe,
uh,
that was 45 and I was 14 years old and
he must've been like 26 or something.
He was wanting to king.
Uh,
and he,
uh,
was,
he was a writing and creating his own
advertising for People for,
for uh,
uh,
clients like all backs and he was doing
an ibm logos,
et cetera.
And um,
he was turning to look at his work.
not that my work is anything near what
his is,
but,
um,
I,
uh,
I was thrilled with the idea that a,
a,
that you could work in a,
as a communicator,
as a designer,
as an advertising guy and uh,
and,
and create your own work and not be a
whore and not,
and not do a,
you have awful,
terrible work.
so that,
that.
Well,
I started in advertising.
I after highschool and music and art,
uh,
that was,
that was basically my,
uh,
my graphic arts training as far as I'm
concerned.
They was in for incredible years.
uh,
I then went to a it to it and I,
and it,
uh,
I met my future wife that first day of
school and I was nuts about it.
And um,
I realized they have to want it to after
a weekend of attracted,
they weren't anywhere near as good as
the high school music and art.
But I stuck it out because I went,
I went into buy the lever and um,
I went to the first year and then the
second year I,
I,
you know,
I didn't cry.
I didn't quite know what to do when I
can,
because I know the school was so awful.
And um,
but I want to buy first clashes.
At the second year they had a,
again,
I ran into another great mentor,
a male teacher,
but marsha levitt and he looked at me
and he was,
he showed what I did for him and he
said,
george,
yes,
and why in school and I should,
I'm trying to make a living,
you know,
and he shed,
get out of,
you're not going to learn any more here.
And he gave me a pivot of piece of paper
with a woman's name who had had a woman
art director,
which are very unique back then who had
an art studio.
And she sent me to him the next night.
The next morning I and I left school in
Michigan in before my,
actually my first seven years started.
I'm a show and achieved good promotion
and advertising,
etc.
It was a great,
great first job because she would have a
superbug designer.
It shows what happened was I lost my
exemption for the army.
It was during the korean war and I got
drafted and a lot of going to Korea came
back alive.
And um,
uh,
she wanted me to be a partner with her
but I didn't want to.
And she said,
what do you want to do?
I really want to work at cbs television
because there was a really dynamic time
with her incorporate imagery and
corporate design with the great bill
golden that,
the head of it.
Okay.
Just if they had just done the cbhi.
So I went into,
at cbs and it was a,
I tell you,
hey,
of design and advertising,
but somehow it wasn't a big,
it wasn't big time advertising to go
with,
uh,
you know,
we worked on products,
etc.
And from then,
so I left there,
you know,
and,
and bill golden a shed to me in
[inaudible] 53 or four,
whatever it was,
54.
Uh,
george,
you can't go out there.
It's a world that the world is terrible.
They will feel exchange.
They will hatch.
And he was right,
you know,
um,
he said,
you not going to be happy,
they're not going to appreciate your
talented and I should.
Well,
I,
somehow something drove me to,
to do it and uh,
you know,
I,
I went and I went and I had that I had
the job I went to was pretty awful.
And I ended a lot of,
a lot of stories,
a seemingly are apocryphal,
but actually true when I kind of acted
up in my first agency,
can overturned the desk at shadows,
did some kind of crazy stuff that,
uh,
after that I,
I went and I worked with somebody great.
The other greAt pioneers in advertising
in and in an inadvertent designer.
Her blue bow and I worked there.
Then I went to the door,
then brought back and work with them for
bill burn back into and bob gauge and,
and um,
and so and,
and again,
I guess something insane,
uh,
I left doyle dane to a bar back and I
told him I was leaving to start the
second creative agency and work with
bill back and started the only creative
agency where the reason I started it,
it was based on the fact that he had
worked with paul rand early in his
career and somehow he understood that
for your work,
but good to have a graphic designer,
especially a one who is prolific and
could write like poetry in that you
could do better advertising if you
worked,
if,
if the,
if there are automatic,
the could work,
could conceive advertising with the
writer,
which up to that time basically all
advertising was a attractor.
Sat in a room with his stomach was and
waited for the creative director for
the,
for the copywriter come in.
So I'm a piece of paper and say,
make a layout yet later shout and the
layout,
you know,
the typical awful,
unambitious layout.
So I left oil.
Dan brought back when I left orlando
brown back,
bill bernbach said to me,
george,
you don't know what's out there.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
the uh,
you know,
they,
and he,
and he literally shut that door they
brought back,
which was basically a creative freak.
They,
that they come,
how they were miraculous.
A group of people as somehow together
could forge a great advertising and it
couldn't happen again.
Uh,
not in,
not in this philistine world,
but I started the agency called pepper
kang.
Lois was that west to writers actually.
And um,
and we were successful almost
immediately,
almost immediately.
And,
and then after a couple of few ca,
one,
two to three years coming out of all my
say what to other agencies,
uh,
you know,
call allie and slos.
And then another guy left my agency and
started going into business with Mary
Wells and started married,
know well,
which green and before you knew it by
the mitch by the mid sixties,
uh,
you know,
I realized that I had triggered with
starting not second,
the creative agency.
I had triggered something call the
creative evolution in advertising and
um,
and uh,
and,
and it,
it,
it became the,
uh,
the uh,
golden age of,
uh,
of,
of advertising in the sixties and
seventies basically was a golden age of
advertising and advertising.
This been,
uh,
you know,
think I hate the show,
which is true.
Um,
you know,
when I first started the show well
before to me that I got a call from one
of the producers and he said,
you know,
we're looking at where we're shooting.
We're doing little spots with the people
who were the original mad men.
He said,
of the period ending I was shooting.
And then they'd named for five or six
people and I'd never heard of a couple
of them.
and I'm a andw ,
w,
wherever,
whoever we talked to.
But matches your name.
I said,
time out.
You're doing a show on the advertising
section.
You'd never heard my name.
He had on order.
We've heard out of bullshit.
You never heard my name as well.
Uh,
okay.
I said,
if you want to know what happened in the
sixties,
if you wanted a real understanding what
happened at 60.
I did a book in 1972 called george.
Be careful,
which is basically a,
you know,
my story about,
uh,
you know,
going up in New York and growing up in
the New York school of design,
I became what it is one to in New York
shoulder and how I started,
you know,
uh,
the creative agency world and how that
became the but,
but,
but it's all about the center.
And um,
and I call the george be careful because
when I was a kid,
uh,
you know,
I remember the hand of god coming into
my,
into my bedroom.
We'll michelangelo's hand said good
george,
be careful.
And my mother's,
my mother told me,
Georgia all my life.
My mother told me,
my father,
my sisters and my coaches and sports.
My,
uh,
my,
when I went into the army and I told him
to be careful and then again,
when you go into advertising,
so that's when everybody tells you to be
careful,
you know,
anything,
anything unusual,
anything over the top,
anything edgy,
you can't do that.
So if there would george be careful with
my anti slow anti slogan and if you want
to know anything about the advertising
in the sixties and the appetite,
he read that book goodbye.
You know,
and I,
you know,
I wish I could fuck you.
And I called it and he called me back a
couple of days later.
I told him to go get the book on amazon
because it was out of her.
He called me up a couple of days later.
They say,
oh jesus,
wow.
We could have done a show on that.
I didn't know shit,
you know,
because of course that would think the
sixties.
Anybody who knows anything,
the media world and anything know
anything about it.
When you mentioned the sixties and you
mentioned advertising in the sixties,
they don't think now they think of the
madman,
of that thumb show before that they
thought of it as a lower gauge of
really,
uh,
of the eight that I was talking to you
about,
about drinking or you know,
when you're leaving doyle dane bernbach
and doe and burbank with a giant part of
it obviously.
And then with the other three or four
agency after that came out of my agency
that was the most a roll cage in media
communications since the year 10 to 12
of the 12 apostles.
Well,
um,
just to oversimplify,
the big idea is to,
is the,
uh,
is,
is a concept that,
that,
that takes the unique selling,
the unique virtues of a product and,
and shaping it into somebody's into
people's minds a that somehow forces a,
a,
a extraordinary sales increase in
whatever you're talking about.
Uh,
but,
you know,
and I always talk about the big idea.
I'm kind of call the best of mr.
Big idea.
Um,
you know,
but what I'm really talking about is,
uh,
is to creativity and I,
and I say creativity can shovel almost
any problem,
you know,
the,
uh,
you know,
the creative act,
there's free of habit by originality can
overcome everything.
But at the same time that I talk about
the creative act,
I really,
I really tell people who are,
who are trying to be to create a work
that creativity isn't really a creative
active back to discovery.
And they look at you like her,
you know.
Um,
and I,
I did a book called,
um,
george on his creation of the big idea,
you know,
where I show 100 things.
I did on the right hand patient on the
left hand page before I show something
in my dna.
Something in my understanding of,
of a shutdown in years of,
of,
uh,
something of my understanding of,
of,
of movies,
of ballet,
of a sports show,
but have a fumo of dirty jokes.
Whenever it is something in there that
inspired what I did.
And I tell,
I tell the young people especially,
um,
you know,
uh,
that,
that background that,
uh,
that,
of,
of high art and pop art at an
intellectual background of understanding
the world around you when,
uh,
and uh,
and,
and especially,
uh,
you know,
the 7,000
years of art is,
is,
uh,
is essential to doing creative work
that,
some of that and that one,
once you have that,
that understanding,
you know,
and,
and that,
that ssl of,
of,
of trying to understand everything when
you have any kind of a problem,
if you then look at the problem and look
at the competitor and etc,
then look at it and get your basic
information.
Once you really understand the problem,
the answer is the answer was there.
It's like floating by,
you know,
you got to do is grab it.
It really isn't an act of creativity
from active discovery.
I sound very mystical talking about it,
but I absolutely,
that's absolutely what creativity is to
me.
I fight,
learn all there is to learn about
something and I know I'm ready to,
to,
to come up with an answer.
It's there and it's not a bolt of
lightening what it is,
it's coming out of your own,
uh,
out of your own essential belief in own
understanding of the world.
The method is,
uh,
is to be interested in everything.
And the,
and the organic part of it is the
passion for,
for everything around you.
The passion for,
you know,
I mean,
I know when I,
when I teach a class,
you know,
at school of visual arts as a favor to
somebody and I'll,
I'll stay till clashes,
get 25 kids,
uh,
once the,
one,
the,
if any,
have been to the museum of metropolitan
museum of art did here.
Okay.
Have you ever been to the moment this
year?
One hand?
Uh,
and if had anybody have any of you never
been to a museum but not,
not,
you know,
five people,
eight people,
you know,
I must style.
Did you know,
I'm just truly astounded,
you know,
talking to design students,
people who were supposed to be
communicated,
you know,
you don't know,
that total.
And that's why when people say today,
wednesday,
the second agent,
the second a credible solution to know,
I said,
I mean,
you got,
you got the,
he got the internet and you've got
google,
we got all the information at your
fingertips to know and nobody they don't
know shit.
Nobody knows shit.
You know,
one of the classic books and
advertising,
one of the great books and advertising
the confessions of an ad man.
Uh,
you know,
by,
uh,
by uh,
david ogleby,
every word in there is the wrong
absolutely wrong.
We want in.
When I was working at doyle dane
bernbach in 1959,
I got conned by his copy chief into
coming to see ogilvy and I said,
I should do.
You're talking to the wrong guy.
Yeah,
I mean,
uh,
and they.
And he begged me to come and I went and
uh,
ogilvy's trying to hire me as their head
art director.
You know,
I think at one point I said I need to
head off to act different if I could
become the they creative creative chief.
He was the creative chief,
creative chief.
I could,
I could do great arbit sizing.
Yeah.
But,
and I told him,
I said,
mr olubayi,
I don't know why you're trying to hire
me because I don't understand one word.
It,
I don't believe I don't,
I don't agree with one word in your
book.
I mean he had,
you know,
here's the rules of addition to the
logo.
It's got to be here.
And he's got me.
He's got rules.
There are no rules and advertise.
It's impossible.
You know,
I mean,
the only rule in advertising,
if there are no rules,
you know,
the best of what shanti and our look at
the new standard,
you know,
I mean it's a company of a,
of a,
of a famous people have people want to
be famous with blurbs all around it and
supposed to be.
And uh,
you know,
just fuck that.
Supposed to be creativity in journalism.
My god,
it's unbelievable.
It's shocking.
I mean,
how can,
how can 200 magazines,
you know,
do the same cover,
that's always there and advertise to go
home and watch advertise.
I watch avatar commercials on tv and I
don't really,
I,
I'm not kidding.
I don't really,
I don't really understand what,
what the hell.
I mean half of them,
I don't understand what they're talking
about.
Yeah.
And,
and most people don't understand,
even if they see something that they
kind of enjoy,
they don't remember the name of the
product,
you know?
So I mean,
I think,
uh,
I don't,
I don't see any,
I mean these people to keep talking
about,
we're on the advent of coming up with
the creative evolution.
I don't see it.
You know,
I don't.
At the same time,
I know there's got to be content that
they,
I don't,
I'm not sure who's telling them what to
do.
Yeah.
You have to have an understanding.
You have to understand,
have an that everything that I got back
to what I said before,
everything you do,
you have to have a shower from.
If you come up with an idea,
a big idea it,
if you,
if you show it to somebody,
your wife,
your friend or a client,
they should go holy shit.
They shave your head coach and go back
and forth,
you know,
it should be such to be such and such a
surprising idea.
The only chance you have to do anything
unless you remember bullshit.
It has to be a shock when you first see
it,
you know,
and what people do is they,
they,
they just.
So the,
so the work is so unAmbitious,
you know,
uh,
I mean television commercials are little
films,
you know,
something's going on and you don't know
what's going on and you say,
well,
what is it about?
And then you're looking for who the
client is.
And then when you see it,
you say,
oh,
I don't get it.
You know,
um,
shot that night trying to,
to.
It's a wasteland of creativity
unfortunately.
And I can't believe they didn't talent
that day because I know I pay people.
I have fans profess,
you know,
a love of my work at set of a set of
standard kind of be something you gotta
learn from it.
I went and got to be learning from it is
that when you do something,
it should be,
it should be a knock out,
an idea,
you know,
and,
and in most cases,
certainly in the,
certainly in an editorial and in which I
already did for 10 years for esquire and
I and I,
you know,
and then now in the museum or not,
but,
uh,
but you have to,
you know,
when you're,
every cover is when it hit,
when it was on a newsstand,
peep some people.
WhAt I mean,
the,
the culture went ape shit on to,
on some of them.
They looked at It like,
whoa,
um,
you know,
go to a new standard today.
There's not a metal boat.
Forget about something being culturally,
being a culture busta.
There's nothing there that you could
possibly remember.
There's an lead today in about her that
today,
but with three magazines I talk about,
they're getting awards,
etc.
Etc.
And you look at the covers and uh,
uh,
I don't know nothing,
you know,
they're all the same cover,
you know.
No,
that's the,
that's the big problem,
you know,
I mean,
I'm talking about people or about a
young design is not,
not being ambitious enough,
etc.
Etc.
One of the problems is,
is that,
uh,
you know,
certainly in,
in magazine design,
there's a lot of terrific talent,
uh,
doing editorial.
I mean,
when you get this society publication
designer sends via,
there were awards every year,
a book,
you know,
and uh,
and you look through it.
And if I've terrific spreads in it,
a lot of exciting stuff going on,
you know,
there's talent there and then they
showed the best coverage of the year and
at they are nothing,
you know,
everything who was the editor,
uh,
you know,
Carolyn Hayes came to me.
He had just basically taken over the
ship of their magazine even though he
had been responsible for the last five
or six or seven issues.
And uh,
he,
he had,
he had been leading in 1960 in 1962
about,
uh,
my,
my ad agency.
And they,
and the reason he,
it struck them was because it was an art
director with the first ad agency
publication lowish,
where there was an art director in the,
in,
in a,
in a masthead.
And the stories were all my advertising,
you know,
every month there was a big story in the
New York times,
at least about campaigns I had done.
So he was looking at the avid art
directors are exciting work and
something made him call me,
uh,
to get advice on how to do coverage.
I'd never done a cover in my life.
and,
and when he called me,
I what I saw him,
I didn't,
I didn't know.
I thought he was trying to get
advertising for our ad agency and I was
being nice to talk to them because I had
been reading a magazine and it was a
terrific magazine.
And he and he basically said,
I need advice,
how do you.
And I said,
well,
how do you do them now?
How do you do your covers now?
He said,
well,
you know,
a five,
four or five or saturday and sit down
with,
for their three or four feet out in
november,
we have a long discussion about,
and we try to come up with the,
uh,
the,
what topic and the issue of coming up
should be the subject of a color.
I said,
yeah.
And then he said,
and that we owe to go away.
We come back two,
three days later,
we,
each of us,
uh,
have one or two ideas on what the cover
should be and maybe it's five or six of
them that we really don't quite know.
So we pick them out,
we comp them up.
And I said,
oh my god,
goop,
fucking grope.
And he said,
huh?
I said,
group grope.
I said that you have to,
when you're work with a male and police
and,
uh,
you know,
and I said,
no,
of course not.
I said,
well,
obviously you don't have anybody there
who knows how to somebody younger
constitutionally,
howard,
why don't we do this?
So go out.
And basically I was saying get a
freelancer.
So he said,
well,
how do you.
I said,
well,
you know,
uh,
you got to get somebody who understands
the culture,
who's kind of added a culture,
who,
uh,
who's literate,
who,
who understands,
who loves politics,
who loves to,
you know,
who likes,
loves the opera theater,
music,
and uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
when you tell a dirty joke and he know
spark somebody understands the culture
and,
and I,
and I shot to give them a couple of
names that make with people might be
able to do it.
And he said he was,
he was southern southern liberal,
kind of an oxymoron.
And he said,
hey pal,
can you do me one favor?
I don't know what the hell you're
talking about.
Can you do me one cover and the one
cover?
Uh,
and uh,
I said,
once you get a bunch of next day she
would do,
went to the next cover,
do.
And he said,
next tuesday,
but now let me give you time.
I said,
I'll do it for next tuesday.
What's an issue?
I don't have it here.
I said,
describe it to tell it,
to scan a sentence for each story.
So told me this,
this,
and one of the things he mentioned was,
um,
uh,
a spread with a photo and a short piece
on floyd patterson,
who was a champion of the world.
And sonny liston was the challenger and
floyd was in the upcoming fight with a
big favorite big five to one favorite
too fast for listing the shadow shadow.
Um,
and I said,
well,
surely issues that have come out,
uh,
the issue will come out a week before
the fight.
I said,
okay.
I went away and I did a cover.
I got a guy who looked like a,
like,
like patterson,
you know,
six foot,
not too muscly.
And I showed him and a call the fight.
I basically shut.
Everybody was wrong about it and he's
not gonna win the fight and he's going
to get,
you're going to get destroyed by
linkedin.
And I show parish and laying flat,
you know,
in the middle of the ring,
left for dead.
You know,
nobody,
nobody in the arena,
the,
his handlers are gone.
The pressure's gone,
20,000
people are gone and it was a metaphor
for a metaphor,
not only for sports but boxing,
you know,
you lose your,
if you're losing it,
you're dead,
you know,
and uh,
but a metaphor for any walk of life,
you know,
when you're lucia,
they leave me for dead.
I'm anyway.
And I and I and,
and the cover and w when he shut,
he called me up and he showed my god I
never saw a couple of my life.
And I said,
yeah,
right.
HE said,
but you're calling the fighting.
No shit,
you're crazy.
Supposedly long.
I said 50 slash 50 chance to right know.
And if I'm right,
you're a genius and if a long time you
know,
hey,
you know,
you played the game but I had on blight,
I've been told that I am absolutely
right.
And anyway,
he,
I found out many years later he ran
because he said he would quit if he,
if a publisher turned it down,
which in fact when the issue came out,
the publisher on king rich wrote a
editorial saying,
you cover,
she our cover.
We have nothing to do with it,
you know,
and it's absolutely true.
Anyway,
when the cover came out,
when,
when the issue came out,
the,
uh,
every,
it was a laughing stock in the sports
world and they hold the young five or
six days later listening,
destroyed them and they were junior ship
landed the biggest douche standard sales
history.
And found out later there were guys,
uh,
the that I've met only a couple of years
ago.
They said when I,
when the cover came out,
they thought it was.
She ended up esquire because they didn't
almost unexpected paycheck.
Anyway.
They were so deeply and read the
magazine.
I found out later that they were really
in trouble naturally.
And what happened from the time I
started doing a coverage to for almost
10 years is to show the circulation went
from 500,000
to 2 million and uh,
you know,
and,
and w with cover after cover,
uh,
you know,
some incredibly controversial,
uh,
but you know,
any math,
the only mash magazine in America that,
that dad speak out against the Vietnam
war.
And in fact,
we,
we were tHe leading,
uh,
we were the leading people in the media,
in,
in America against the Vietnam war.
And,
uh,
and in the support of muhammad ali,
which I would've hated to a fighter at
the time of,
uh,
after it became a muslim and a and a,
and refused to fight in,
in that terrible war,
you know,
so,
uM,
uh,
and,
and it only happened because of page
because people say,
boy,
he took trump boss covers when I was in
boston,
the recovered it took him boss to run
it,
you know.
And in fact,
you know,
uh,
I said I'd call them up and I'd say a
watch.
I was sending a cover that one.
And I,
and I always chose my own shop,
a topic for what he showed me.
Sometimes he show,
he talked about the,
uh,
what was coming up with a magazine.
And I,
and I knew the topic that he was
basically excited about with the one I
had to do because it was that important.
But in many times I,
I picked the,
you know,
like that cover I did,
like I told you about for the first
issue with listed,
whether it was just the spread that they
put it in at the last Minute,
you know,
but,
uh,
but I,
I call him up and I say,
I said I about the get the high world
and uh,
and I said this one's going to read and
get us in trouble and didn't say,
yeah,
you know,
and when I'm in trouble,
I meant a,
he would lose,
not only would it be get bombed to his
bike saturdays and congressmen and god
knows who and,
and,
and.
Right.
And people writing in your death threats
sometimes,
you know,
losing a advertising client because he
had,
they had many clients down southville
where they get a lot of uh,
uh,
you know,
men's wear and a lot of mills went down
south and,
and,
and there was a time of the jim crow
south.
I mean,
it was a time of real racism going on in
America with dick.
I wish racism in America,
but that,
which one?
It was a rabbit and ramping,
no,
it's changing for worse because I'm,
um,
somehow,
you know,
growing up with the internet and growing
up on the stuff on the screen and
filling it,
filling the page with information,
look at,
look at motion magazines,
state,
look at even the great magazines today,
you know,
and like a vanity fair.
It's just jammed with and New York that,
that is just jammed with information and
copy of cetera.
It's almost like it's an extension of,
of the tb,
of the,
of what people were used to.
I mean,
when you're talking about white space in
which we used to be a big thing in,
in,
in school,
in graphic art school in god.
Yet we've tAlked about hate that white
space.
But they knew what they were talking
about.
They were talking about she,
which sometimes wait,
that's an idea that should,
that so that you need the expansIon you
need to know.
And you know,
the great pioneers in advertise in
editorial design in,
in the twenties and thirties was a guy
named dr argo and alexey brodovitch for
vogue magazine.
And,
um,
and uh,
you know,
the,
the irving penn's and avid dons and all
graphic design learn somehow from that
kind of experience of the,
of,
uh,
of a spread that had some kind of
vitality to it.
And um,
and uh,
when you look at the internet,
there's a load of information,
but there's no,
they're not designed right calorie and
then no attempt for design,
vitality.
I mean even most people's websites where
you have a chance to,
to do something,
to express something and it's not so
much,
you know,
I'm not down on the ipad or whatever
they do,
but I'm,
I'm,
I'm for the magazine.
I fought a visual,
a excitement of magazine.
I mean,
to this day,
yeah,
when I get magazines and they don't have
to be even be a great magazine,
you know,
you turn the page read,
when you lay it on your,
when you lay it on your knees,
that's like a lap dance.
You know,
I mean,
it's a official thing,
you know,
and I can't see,
uh,
you know,
I mean if I was a really young,
a young man today,
a good to shape,
what would,
what would you do?
The website we do and I'd be,
I'd created a magazine.
Yeah.
I create a magazine,
have people say,
holy shit.
Did you see that cover?
Then open,
like,
wow,
we should do it.
It's the,
it's the,
it's,
it's a,
it's a revolution in journalism,
you know,
the,
a graphic dEsigner,
you know,
who,
who understands them ideas and
understands that I,
that I did what their make that makes
world go around,
could change the world with a magazine.
If it did one talent could do it right
now.
And everybody was stopped at the
magazines.
I've tried,
I've tried it.
It's funny because some people said,
well,
you know,
have you ever thought about cheyenne had
been,
you want a movie director or this,
of that?
And I said,
yeah,
well when I've able to beat it to be,
to work on and being a graphic designer
and being an advertising,
etc.
It was,
I,
I've done hundreds,
thousands of commercials,
you know,
music,
video,
video ever done to this day joke.
I'm in cocoa loaded still sessions,
the best music video ever.
Uh,
you know,
I thought that the shells,
films that would knock it down,
it was so exciting.
Uh,
you know,
I do,
I design logo design packages,
you know,
uh,
I,
I designed an agency or a design space,
you know,
uh,
I mean every part of,
um,
uh,
you know,
I could,
I could be a renaissance man in a sense
doing all of those things.
And um,
uh,
including,
um,
uh,
I,
the,
the concept for New York magazine and
actually the first design for the first
logo for New York magazine I did as a
supplement for the herald tribune in
1962 or three.
Um,
and in fact it was at my office one day,
I think it was 63,
it might've been 62.
And,
uh,
he showed me working at a magazine and
he said,
well,
what he,
he took,
what are you doing?
I didn't want to,
I'm,
I'm doing the,
I do the advertising for the New York
herald tribune and he knew that because
I was doing a very excited to paint who,
uh,
who says a newspaper has to be taught,
in fact,
that was producing a commercial for the
tribune every night,
get the front page and,
and write a write a script and the
shooting script in a cab and produce a
commercial every night.
They would go on every night again,
in any case.
And I,
and I,
it was a big success and I said,
well,
I see the selling the hell out of the
newspaper.
Uh,
danny paper,
the sunday paper,
I can't do anything with it.
Could,
you can't compete with the ties or
they're sticking it in a show.
I've been doing a supplement of trying
to get them to understand that they can
do a supplement called New York.
And if you did it right,
you do a beautifully designed to get
terrific writing,
etc cetera.
And it could be a combination of the,
of,
uh,
I said of the,
of the new yorker andq magazine,
you're telling you about specific things
to do,
uh,
and if you did that,
you know,
you can sell another 200,
300,000,
400,000
copies just because a terrific
supplement.
And uh,
and lookIng at it,
and this was,
I've only been doing covers for them for
half a year or so.
And he said,
george,
if you,
if I left esquire right now and you left
your agency,
we should do this magazine and we should
do bag of scenes because it's a city
magazine.
And he said,
and we could do a city magazine for
seven or eight bucks,
here's a card preppy.
And I remember it was second saying,
holy shit,
that's a real big idea.
That's big thing.
And I've got hiM to do it.
But I had an ad agency and he and he was
doing.
But when you say why didn't,
why didn't I do it now?
I said,
well,
you know,
it's not that I'm old and tired because
we actually don't.
I suPposedly retired in to the year 2000
and my wife says,
I'm not tired,
I'm just,
I'm not retired,
I'm just tired,
but I'm not because I work all the time.
I worked with my A look and we do stuff
all the tIme with doing advertising.
Yeah,
we're working on a script and shooting
script for a tv special,
a set,
et cetera,
et cetera.
but,
uh,
you know,
you have a hotel.
I might do a magazine.
I would have to do work with a,
a,
a direct,
uh,
an editor who basically treated me the
way howard and treated me as a,
as a big talent.
Uh,
he took me at least as good as he
treats.
He treated the gates,
elise,
you know,
and that's what he did with me.
He said,
you know,
your ideal,
your ideal with the releases and the,
and the male is the initiative and the
lowest isn't.
And they do that thing.
That doesn't mean he didn't edit those
guys,
you know,
and which he absolutely did,
because even a great writer leach
editing.
Um,
but,
uh,
he didn't edit it.
He didn't edit or change one thing on
anything.
I have a dead.
I mean,
would I dished up?
And he was like,
holy shit,
wow,
you know,
I love it,
or a wow,
am I going to be in trouble here?
You know?
And uh,
and of course he loved the whole concept
of beIng in trouble because being in
trouble meant,
uh,
meant that people,
that he knew,
that he knew that a magazine had I had
to be dynamic and how to have the ideas.
And he also understood something that
people know it as the worst understands
today.
And that is,
you don't write,
you don't create a magazine for your,
you don't do a pickup,
you don't take a poll,
you know,
like,
yeah,
like the politician don't find out what,
what they think and what they want.
What do you mean,
what they want?
What do you mean?
What they want?
They're supposed to be above and beyond
that,
you know,
uh,
the culture you're supposed to be
leading the culture.
She to be ahead because he's supposed to
be telling people what the hell you
think is exciting and dynamic and,
and,
uh,
and thought provoking and,
and do it and do it your way.
And that's the way you could create a
great margaret.
And then if you do it to see if you do
it that way with all that kind of
passion and a talent,
you'll get an audience.
You know,
we got all audience,
our patient with a at esquire 60,
the audience basically.
I'm not sure.
I never find out what the real numbers
were,
but I think at a trauma,
a,
a half of the circulation.
I'm making it up a college with college
students.
Yeah.
I run into people all the time.
I finish a day who,
uh,
you know,
who were in their twenties when I was
doing coverage in the sixties,
you know,
and uh,
and now nowadays 60,
a 60 years old and a boy,
they know every cover they taught.
They can tell you how the coverage
changed their law,
that changed their lives.
They can tell you,
they can tell.
The people tell me where they were when
they show the ali cover.
I think sebastian,
they can tell.
They tell me when,
when,
where they were,
when they sort of cover that.
That's the kind of,
uh,
of uh,
you know,
and I will call them a pictorial zola's.
You know,
what's funny is I said toilet zola's to
somebody a couple of months ago when
they said what to pick zola door.
Um,
you know,
wHat I explained to jack huge.
They still didn't get it,
but any case,
you know,
and,
and I,
and I call myself a,
a cultural provocateur and I call myself
a cultural product toward my advertising
pto because when you create adverTising,
it's not just to sell a product or a
person or an idea it,
it should go beyond that.
It should,
it cAn touch sometimes very dynamIcally
on the,
on the culture and it there's no way you
can't do great advertising mess.
You understand that it shouldn't,
you shouldn't just be selling a product
you shouldn't be talking about in the
culture or where the culture should be
headed.
P,
I talked to that,
but I took,
I tell students that the young people
and young people in advertising that
they don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about it.
They don't Get it until I show examples.
You know what?
So when you say what excites me most,
an appetite he was on,
I took something and made and made it
into a giant part of the culture.
Um,
uh,
and,
that's,
that was the most thrilling,
you know,
uh,
of the things that I worked on and I've
done a couple of doesn't like that.
Um,
the,
the esquire covers.
What I was most excited about was,
um,
the antiwar stuff,
you know,
stuff that woke up and help walk,
wake up America and,
and uh,
and,
and woke up people to the,
to the greatness of muhammad ali because
when I did that cover of a hammer to
leave st bastian,
he was,
he was.
I mean,
if there was a poll on it that 80
percent of the country,
white and black were against him.
And,
um,
and the,
that cover enough of a shelf help change
the american attitude about the war and
directly directly helped change martin
luther king from shane to all of the
sudden the,
uh,
all,
all his older black leaders that he
would keep out of talking to or against
the Vietnam war because she didn't want
to piss off a johnson because johnson
was a,
was a pioneer in,
in helping,
uh,
in,
in helping,
uh,
you know,
you're fortunate,
what civil rights laws,
uh,
what,
the check and he came out against it
defending muhammad ali and against the
war.
Uh,
he wAsn't deep shIt with the johnson.
so I mean,
uh,
I think,
a of a lot of things I've done that
helped change the culture,
you know,
I mean,
that's the stuff that you really
remember.
I mean,
uh,
yeah,
I,
I stayed,
I would do a magazine.
You know what?
I probably would start an ad agency and
show everybody how much done,
you know,
uh,
additionally,
there was an article I read day.
I,
what's funny is you're,
you're,
you read 30 magazines,
you can't remember where you read it,
you know,
in the old days if esquire,
what?
Esquire,
what am I covered?
Do you remember where you show up?
But that's beside the point.
Uh,
but uh,
uh,
it was an article,
got the head of the largest agency in a
world publish ashish.
I guess Joe Levy ain't go with questions
and answer.
It goes on and on and on.
He talks about his technology.
I mean,
if he had not one fucking word talking
about his ad age that mentioned
creativity,
it's like,
it's like a,
like it's got nothing to do.
The product got nothing to do with what
they do,
what they know about it.
It's shocking,
you know?
Uh,
that's the way it used to be with all
the ada.
Does she have.
I remember they would agency,
like ogilvy made it,
you know,
after david ogilvy,
he died and they,
and they would,
they talked about and the jewish,
I,
they,
they sold themselves on the fact that
there were scientific agency and a sense
that they did this great research,
you know,
and the little,
and I told everybody,
you know,
advertising isn't a science,
it's an art.
Tell me shy.
Um,
and,
and your most,
at most,
the most advertised,
most people in the day,
most people in the who judge advertising
in a,
in,
in the world,
uh,
in certainly in America.
They've all got their marketing schools
and communication schools and when they,
and they been taught or that advertising
and marketing is a science because how
do you teach it for the art?
You know,
I mean,
what would the school say for
advertising and marketing know why I
didn't teach that,
you know?
Um,
so,
um,
so to this day,
the way you show a client,
most clients or something and understand
something really edgy and uh,
and they'll look at it and they'll say,
very interesting.
I'll hand it to somebody who's sitting
next to him with a senior vp and say to
a very interesting research it and find
out,
find out if I like it,
you know,
um,
there's,
there's not,
there's no people that are talking about
the creativity of something,
you know,
uh,
it's astounding in all walks of life,
you know,
I mean starting with the head of one of
those giant ad agencies go.
But I was totally by elgar.
He made it and I remember the woman was
the head of the agency.
She went on and on and on and on and on
about that because the,
uh,
the way they research,
et etc cetera,
and it's about time were,
were,
were not.
One mention of creativity.
I mean,
and,
and people like bill bird back when he
did doyle,
dane bernbach or people like me with
papa kate,
lois and Mary Wells,
wells rich greene,
you know,
that,
that's all we talked about was
creativity.
What the fuck else is there to talk
about?
That's the name of the game,
mr.
Product,
you know,
it's when you,
when you talk to a guy who,
uh,
to,
to malali at the ford,
he talks about the car,
but the product,
you know.